me
ah ah ah ah ah
no
come over here so it's okay big Bach
power
tan
aname not included
ana
can you do
[music]
animejapan
tan tan
male
ni
[music]
Yeah,
why are you dreaming
?
It's nice to meet you, I'm Seiji and my lover, and it's chestnut day
.
"
Ame
ahaan," what a good thing this guy
is.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
is Seiji-san hated by his little sister
?  Hey
[Music
] Chibi monkey flower
again C Pooh Hey,
I made a bento for Seiji-kun, but
you always eat the ones you bought, right?
I don't know
what I like about lunch, so if there's something you don't like, tell me.I'll do
my best as my future wife, so tell me already.
I'm sorry that I
don't want to talk about my house so much, so
let's eat
.
If I talk about Hikaru Aka-san, someone will laugh at me, even my relatives
will hate me.
It's another girlfriend of Mr. Haha,
that's an ability, who is it?
It's nothing but a ranker
, hmm, you must be having a hard time with this nismo,
too.
I heard
that you're going to be
4 a,
yeah, yeah, 4th place
, but here you
go,
wh,
you said unrealistic things like you're a devil.
[
Music] I have it.  I was going to the place,
but is it there Is
this frame there? Is my mother still there?
[music]
goodgood
ana
rar
8 n
uh
ah ah ah I
'm so scared par 4 par 4
boo boo I'm not strong anymore after all it feels good slippery summer open
ana are you do
ah
ah ah ah ah ah don't touch it cheaply
so finally the two of us are alone tanba
Don't worry when I hear that Strauss is
out.  I think
[music]
[applause]
I'm here.
I don't know
well  It
's been years
since I've carried Evil on
my back.  It's always been
your big
brother
.  If you think that you've become obedient like a mecha girl,
sisters are strange things,
aren't they?
The result of the teacher's legend I
'm going to eat it again at the autograph session to commemorate the release of the final volume There are a lot of apples near my parents' house
I wonder if it's been springing up all the time, haven't I tried it?
I think it's nice
to play with the bait with Seiji-san Waiting for warriors
Holding pasta and a cutter
[Music]
You don't like running, but you're fast.  I mean,
Miki-chan, you
're a beautiful man and a beautiful woman You must be a
tapplitter in disguise My
boyfriend seems to be kind
, but I
let
you go.
You said you were already busy with work today, so why didn't you put something else in?
What is this 1 q 2
?
But ah, that's the same as the one I got
.  I don't know what
it is, but I feel like I'm being blamed by my
ma  We enjoyed each other, so it's a joke, ah ah
ah ah stop this ah ah ah
stop giving it to a girl what are you thinking
what  Hey, you're the worst, and you should apologize to everyone
[Music]
-29-6 Don't underestimate women!
]
No, it's scary, it's the
last parka, isn't it Mr. T
?
Huh,
I've become more and more confused about what
a couple is.
Dogen
is the former batter,
but do you know what will happen
?  Hey, sour,
what are you good at auto again? It's
rude
.
Okay autoplay It's all right It's all right It's all right
Where does your head confidence come from?
Oh, that reaction, it
really happened! It's early in the morning.
No, the adult
line is about to
begin So are you
going to take
class too?  You're ignoring me, aren't you
shaved?
They're probably
already tired.
Even if
you look at the star girl, she's just an ordinary character, isn't she?
Well, I heard
[music]
Know that and avoid it It's
true that it's from the dirt and it's okay to say something like purple gun
With this,
it looks
like we've parted ways I don't know Is this really the end?
It doesn't seem likely,
so I've said that from the beginning.
Believe in the rum of Datsu's lovers
Which one won't be able to work as a shopkeeper?
I don't care about the road I gave to Mr.
gree I stopped him Cupid escort It's time to get serious and train
Don't hesitate to support Gary, then Tiara-san won't
have a job.
Mr. is currently out of the couple with me, so the protection of tax revenue is dancing.
I'm waiting for slip now I'm embarrassed if I get stabbed
D Seiji-kun's Dawn company Chasing me and taking turns It was strange that I had 3 eyes
Then I should try to pull it out, because it was in a magazine, so I
took a cold attitude with a case
na na  na na
oh
shiro I put it back on its own I have to
kiss again I'm sorry to
say it but
Yamada Kiki's
grave price is gentle now Sex itself is annoying play
[music]
This is really going to be the way I am
[Applause]
[Music] Yes
tee I'm
still Tom
God existed ana Maybe I was
born sugar
ani
me
n ame
nao
's shop yeah
ni
me
me even
[  Applause]
[music]
[applause]
Tenjin
faa
[music]
ana
[applause]
[music]
It was a good point.
year old
t point
eeeeee
bejean